every now and then a politician
unintentionally reveals who he really is
in what he really believes I could teach
anybody even people in this room don't
no offense intended to be a farmer you
it's a processor you dig a hole you put
a seed in you put dirt on top add water
up comes the corn then we had 300 you
could learn that first how much would
you pay to see Bloomberg trying to dig
ditches for eight hours a day maybe run
a bush hog or tend a livestock in the
hot Sun I'd pay a lot of money
personally now second what if snobby
elitist comment that is now farmers as
you might imagine we're not at all
amused they were lighting up Twitter it
was hilarious but I have to say to be
fair there's context context to explain
these comments from Bloomberg now look
at this headline in the Milwaukee
Journal Sentinel today Bloomberg appears
to be insulting farmers but there's more
to the story now I have a question
why don't conservatives ever get the
same chance to explain our context
because for us there's never more to the
story they just jump to boycotts and
total condemnation nevertheless here's
more of what Bloomberg did say you have
300 years of the industrial society you
put the piece of metal on the lathe you
turn the crank in the direction of the
arrow and you can have a job the
information economy is fundamentally
different because it's built around
replacing people with technology you
have to have a lot more gray matter a
lot more gray matter oh boy well sure of
course he's right about technology
changing the type of work we do that's
not exactly a novel concept but can you
imagine if Donald Trump said anything
approaching this now the media who are
rushing in to provide context of
Bloomberg would proclaim that Trump was
just insulting the intelligence of
others
anytime president Trump's team tried to
provide context after anything that
people considered controversial like
Charlottesville or after his comments
about where the refugees we admit come
from they're just ignored but it's not
just the farmers that Bloomberg has no
respect for remember that Texas Church
shooting in late December when an armed
citizen Jack Wilson saved countless
lives by shooting the killer dead
this was Bloomberg's take away lesson
it's you just do not place yeah they're
too stupid to defend themselves or
others through the use of a firearm that
they carry says a man who has
round-the-clock security and has had it
for decades by the way all armed and we
all know what he thinks about overweight
Americans you're all just too thick to
be able to control your own drink size
and your intake the Board of Health's
limit on the serving size of sugary
drinks does not limit anyone's
consumption it just requires them to
think about whether they really want
more than 16 ounces in a restaurant 16
ounces is the maximum that they would be
able to serve in one cup we're not
taking away anybody's right to do things
we're simply forcing you to understand
that you have to make the conscious
decision to go from one cup to another
cup forcing you to understand don't you
think they're probably a lot of things
he would force us to understand if he
were president now how does Bloomberg
view people of faith well he sent that
message loud and clear when he was mayor
of New York at least on the 10th
anniversary of September 11th he
included not a single faith leader in
the list of speakers at that service
when he was called on it this is what
mayor snob said there is this separation
of church and state in our Constitution
the Constitution doesn't say that clergy
should know a role you shouldn't but you
can't explain me which clergy do you
want your religion my religion her
religion okay priest rabbi Imam Minister
amazing pretty much covers it doesn't it
he was dripping with condescension and
remember on the respect front while
we're talking about the respect front
now women
you think about the whole thing women
aren't really respected as women who can
have different views in the Democrat
Party because if they're pro-life the
entire party has driven pro-life women
from their ranks they basically said as
much women who are pro-life
are not welcome and Bloomberg's gonna
fit in just fine there he's personally
contributed check this out
14 million dollars to Planned Parenthood
from 2014 to 2017 figures probably up by
now five point eight million to women's
vote that's Emily list pack that since
2012 any headline emily's list 2018 New
York City convention now remember
emily's list claims that it's just for
electing more women to Congress you look
at their little website and that's what
they say 50,000 women but of course what
they really mean is mo more pro-abortion
women to Congress the party of inclusion
is the opposite it's more restrictive
than it was 20 years ago in the Democrat
Party when you really think about this
and I thought I thought about a lot
today their big tent collapsed and that
tent has been replaced by a safe space
for leftist victims only think about
Senator Joe Manchin of West Virginia
he's basically a walking Democrat
stegasaurus he's pro-gun and he's
pro-life not gonna be many more of him
anytime soon imagine what a oc+ three
say about someone like Manchin behind
closed doors get out of here now at the
core of all of this it's not just
snobbery it's not reason yeah yeah it's
that but it's a deep and unwavering
contempt for traditional American ideals
because in this elitist view of
sanctimonious snobs the rights to life
and to liberty without which the pursuit
of happiness is meaningless a reserved
only for those who truly deserve to have
them you have to think the right way to
have them and Bloomberg he's kind of a
miniature pony trotting a well-worn
Democrat path there from Hillary's
deplorable z-- to Obama's bitter
clingers the left loves to trash the
man while claiming to stand up for him
and their media allies of course they're
all too happy to echo the hatred let's
stop calling Trump voters idiots and
fools and call them what they are drug
addicts anybody who enables yeah
anybody who votes for and supports a
racist is a racist you are culpable
white America I'm sorry if you vote for
Trump you're the bad guy so you get the
idea if you're woke you're in luck if
not you'll be demeaned or driven out or
just expunged now many mike is singing
from that same hymnal and that's the
angle